what's up everyone it's B Escape here
and welcome to the first episode of only
use GE the idea of this series is that I
am never allowed to leave the grand
exchange ever meaning that there's only
a few limited number of things that I
could do here such as cutting down the
trees within the enclosure killing the
imps and selling items to the Grand
exchange so flipping will be my best
Money Maker for this account seven
simple rules are going to be followed
throughout the series the first one is
that I cannot trade any other players
directly or pick up items that are
dropped by them rule number two only
starting items will be those from the
tutorial Island which are currently in
my inventory and I'm going to sell those
in just a few moments rule number three
like I said before no leaving the grand
exchange ever rule number four no
trading items from an alternate account
I can't log onto my main and give this
account a whole bunch of stuff that will
benefit it there's no trading rule
number five Training skills without
leaving the grand exchange is allowed so
I can train wood cutting fir making
Fletching crafting you know what have
you rule number six cutting the trees in
the grand exchange enclosure and killing
the Imp is allowed so if the imps were
well lucky enough to drop a bead I could
pick that up and then sell that rule
number seven I can do random events if I
get them and I was fortunate enough to
get the strength potion Once I arrived
in lumbridge as soon as I came out of
tutorial Island Dr jaal came up to me
for the random event I did not have a
Guam Leaf to give to him and he gave me
this potion and hopefully it sells for a
few hundred coins so that's a good kick
start to this account I guess anyways
we're going to sell everything in my
inventory except the axe and Tinder Box
and let's see how many coins we get
let's take a look at my trading log and
everything sold for a total of 981 GP so
now it's time to go cut down some trees
around the grand exchange so 25 logs
would sell for 1,200 coins I'm thinking
that I might buy a knife and then turn
all of these into Arrow shafts and then
buy some feathers and then turn them
into headless arrows and I'm going to
see if that will make a better profit
let's take another look at the trading
log and a knife cost me 98 GP after
buying feathers and selling more
headless arrows and repeating the
process over and over I'm left with a
total of
1,633 coins my Fletching level is also
five and my wood cutting is level seven
it probably would have been better to
sell the logs raw but I got some good
Fletching XP and at higher levels I
think Fletching will be a valuable Money
Maker so now I'm going to buy a steel
axe since I can now use one of these for
wood cutting so let's click here and 826
coins let's raise this hopefully it
doesn't sell for this much all right 60
coins that's actually really good I
thought that was going to just take away
my whole cash deck now let's go cut down
some more trees and make more money so I
found my first couple imp right in the
corner of The Grandin exchange I'm
punching this first one to death and
hopefully he drops something decent and
I probably should have saved my bronze
sword let's see what he drops ashes and
clay and I just had my first successful
flip I bought 168 oak logs for 29 coins
a piece and sold them for 31 coins a
piece resulting in almost a 400 coin
profit which was really nice with my
little cash stack I also have level 13
Fletching and 15 wood cutting as well
well so I'm going to cut down even more
trees and hopefully I get a larger cash
deck and we'll get into some bigger
flips now I'm level four attack from the
imps and only one more level until I can
equip a steel dagger to kill them even
faster I also have 10 Ash drops from
them some bronze bolts clay raw chicken
an egg pot of flour and a hammer I also
have another 840 headless arrows so now
we're going to sell everything and that
brings my GP total to
9,071 coins now let's see if I can get
another successful flip
and now I'm level five attack just off
of imp that's really impressive and now
we're going to check up on the grand
exchange offer once I kill this imp and
see what he drops hopefully it's a bead
let's see what it is and Ashes and Ashes
so I bought 335 oak logs and I think I
bought them for 27 coins a piece and now
I'm going to sell them for 29 resulting
in almost a 700 coin profit let's just
check this right now let's click here
and all right 27 coins let's take these
and now we're going to sell them for
29 okay and they're not going to sell
right away I just have to be patient and
wait and they sold 9,715 coins we are
almost at the 10K threshold so I'm going
to try oak logs again and I'm going to
show you all how I do this so I take a
log and I basically increase the price
just randomly and they sell for 30 coins
a piece now this is going to be the sell
part of the flip and you kind of want to
take this price and then reduce it by
one coin so I'm going to sell them for
29 coins a piece then we sell them hit
confirm and then we have 28 coins for
the sell so this would be our Buy offer
and we would increase this number by one
so the sell what we would be selling
these at would be 29 coins and the buy
would be at 29 coins so oak logs are no
longer good right now at the moment the
prices always fluctuate so I can check
on oak logs in about 10 to 15 minutes or
maybe even longer but we could try a
different log let's try say you logs why
not let's try to go with a bigger flip
so let's increase the price of this one
ulog sells for
447 so this would be
446 then we would take the ulog in our
inventory hit confirm and 444 we would
increase that by one so I could buy
these for 445 coins a piece and then
sell them for 446 coins a piece this is
pretty much not worth it because that's
only a one coin difference so I'm going
to try and find a different item I just
found an awesome flip I bought 421 bomb
leaves for 23 coins a piece resulting in
9.6k and the sell price for them are
going for 33 coins a piece now I'm going
to definitely have to wait this one out
because I don't know how often these
Guam leaves sell or if people even buy
them from the grand exchange but this
will be a nice flip almost resulting in
a 4K profit if successful and they sold
that is really awesome let's check the
grand exchange and we have 13.8k so we
finally reached the 10K threshold and
now we have 14k cash deack so let's try
the Guam leaves again and I'm going to
show you how I do this so I just buy
them and they're actually not even going
for anywhere near 100 coins so 34 coins
that is the sell price so let's decrease
that by one sorry so that's 33 coins and
now let's just sell this one I have so
we'll do one and the Buy price is 22
coins now since that is such a large gap
I increase this Buy offer by a few more
coins just so I'm more likely to get the
sell of the Guam leaves to anyone who is
selling them on the grand exchange so
I'm going to buy these for 23 coins like
I just did before so let's do Guam Leaf
grimy and I'm going to buy them for 23
each and I'm going to buy as many as I
can so I think this is good enough all
right 607 now so 23 coins and then I'm
going to sell them for 33 coins a piece
and they finally sold I had to decrease
the price of them to 32 coins because
they were not selling for 33 as quickly
as I expected and they sold pretty fast
for 32 and that's only a one coin
difference so let's collect these from
the previous offer and let's collect
these so that made me about 5.7k and I
think I'm going to keep flipping the
Guam leaves until they are not worth
flipping so I bought 788 grimy Guam
leaves for 25 coins a piece and sold
them for 33 coins so let's collect the
profit and we're now at 26k and I
believe they're still going well so
we're going to try and do another flip
my next flip was for 63 Grimmy har
Landers and I bought 63 at 285 coins
each and and then sold them for 372 and
that made me about 6K now I think I'm
going to wrap it up for today's episode
and in the meantime I'm going to do some
more wood cutting and Fletching I'm
currently level 28 level 20 and my
attack is five and my strength is four
so pretty good for the first episode if
you all liked it remember to leave a
like and also comment if you have any
feedback for me or any suggestions and
overall remember to subscribe for more
of these episodes thank you all for
watching and I'll see you all later